[Music]
in co-ed band news Anna band be a n
[Music]
submitted by duffle bag that's a nice
name
cuz it good name men and woman have been
banned from eating together in Indonesia
Indonesia Indonesian oh wait they're
Catholic out there no it's already
Catholic majority Muslim really yeah
Indonesian Sharia oh I'm so sorry yeah
Indonesia and has a lot of mysteries
sorry yeah sorry yeah with a shoddy
shoddy keep going yeah so there's this
Indonesian district which is the most in
servitude I think you're gonna say
Indonesia and disk jockey I made more
sense than disc jockey no that's such an
old word somebody's just a DJ anyway
okay so this district here it's one of
the country's most conservative regions
and they just passed this law saying
that single women cannot eat with men so
they have to be accompanied by their
spouse or close male relative oh yeah
yeah eat with another man
you mean like have lunch yeah well how
are they good what about the man sorry
Islamic law oh yeah yeah I'm supposed to
go on a date you gotta you got a date
and private I'll just get straight to
the marry arranged marriage like a
betrothal damn yeah and so now they've
announced that
how does the country feel about it like
yeah we were wanting this for years well
from what I read it's not like it
doesn't seem like they're too happy
about it I asked my grandma like back in
a day I was like how did dudes hit on
you and she's like they would ask us to
go get some tea but we would always have
a chaperone or something yeah a dancer
they can't be unaccompanied yeah then
she was like we would never walk
side-by-side together
oh uh well she was also like she says
that in her era people were starting to
become more independent and start like
she said commoners were dating but then
she's kind of like foofy-foofy
aristocratic Li or whatever you call it
like she's just high society so then it
was different for her but they kept the
tradition of the old-school [ __ ] but it
wasn't illegal but she would say like
yeah like if they go on a date well
first off there's no date like the way
that we know it's more of an
introduction because you only you have a
handful of introductions with men to
figure out if you want to marry one of
these guys so you get yes you get a
couple of chances to kind of like see if
you connect you have dinner with them or
Lodge like suitors that come visit your
house yeah that your your family
approves of and then like so for example
like let's say before if you in case
both of your parents were cool with it
then you would have like a chaperone
that is that your parents trust that
would come along and you guys would go
date yeah like the old Asian movies yeah
so like let's say if Anthony was the
chaperone like Anthony and Casey would
kind of like walk as buddies in front
and then you would be in the back I'm
like Danis um sad ass [ __ ] Wow
yeah when we were in Barcelona we
visited this really famous house like a
gaudi house and by the fireplace I think
of Gaudi house was that Daddy Honda no
Gaudi he's that baby and then like it
was like near the heat source area they
a bench that was for two people on one
side and one person on the other and
that was for this oh damn
anyway so this thing here they're saying
they're also said that they will
restrict food sellers to serve women
after 9:00 p.m. unless they're
accompanied by a spouse or a relative
and so they're saying I can't even like
get food if they're single after 9:00
p.m. no lesbians have lunch no that's
against Islamic law - yeah you can't
have lesbians in Malaysia they got one
or flogged they got they got flogged and
no can't came oh [ __ ]
that's the word he made in Malaysia that
came to women for being lesbian lovers
being lovers and they got caught in a
car by officers yeah there were 22 and
32 ah I think there always had to be a
chaperone because like there always had
to be a witness that the that the girl
is a virgin at all times they don't get
to pinky pinky on the day or like so
then they can't be accused of anything
because that's their value goes down and
they can't it's harder for them to get
married I think that's why it's like oh
I heard that they were alone like but
they're just drinking tea together
oh yeah but there was like 30 minutes of
them no one no knows where they went and
enter like oh they could have done it so
it's to protect the the the the I guess
like the the crane value the value the
cria the the integrity the integrity of
the female to my witness yeah what's the
policy of Sharia of - dogs are the same
sex [ __ ] my gift are you because if
they if you beat lesbian women right
which is really really [ __ ] up dogs
have I can dogs be gay my girl dogs hump
each other all the time that's what I'm
saying some water do they go and they
kick these dogs away they're like
statues all attractions
animal instinct to like get something
dominant so I don't really know it's a
certainty dominance right I think so I
wouldn't be half the time anyway right
mm-hmm I'm always dominating your ass
this is just like old old laws that
people still stand by and it's so crazy
that sometimes I forget you know how
they say like when Americans travel they
act like they rule everything I kind of
feel like I do that on accident not
because I want to but because we're so
free and entitled to our freedom that I
forget like especially when we're
Malaysia and then we were on a radio
show and they're like talking about
college and we're like oh yeah we don't
really need college and they're like oh
actually can you not say you don't need
college can you say that you need
college and I'm like then don't ask me
for my opinion if I can't be real with
it that's my American thinking right
like what cuz of the government right
they were like the government doesn't
allow that yeah they're doing that
campaign on why college is important at
the time but I was just like damn dude
something as simple as that like we
really take our feet freedoms for
granted because we I couldn't say that
in Malaysia they were terrified they
were so scared to say yeah you don't
really need college or even hugging
right you can in hug well guys can't hug
women yeah like in public yeah it's
interesting there because like they only
kind of police the Muslim community so
they don't care if you're like Chinese
or white or whatever in Malaysia but
then like yeah they were even saying
like during I think it's Ramadan but
when you when they can't have alcohol or
whatever
don't be special like Sharia like police
that come in and they would check the
IDS of the Malays and then they'll be
like oh [ __ ] you drink in all right boom
you're going to jail buddy but they
don't care if Chinese people do it
because they're like oh yeah you Chinese
yeah bring tourism capitalism and
economy it's where they don't they're I
guess they don't I think for them it's
like the sure
la is only for the Muslims yeah and and
it's like mainly the ethnic Malays are
Muslim so then that's kind of cool
though it's kind of like you police
yourself but then but then like you know
like if I'm a tourist and I'm there and
I'm drinking on Ramadan like they don't
they don't I don't get in trouble yeah
what what brought on this change why all
of a sudden I'm not sure they're just
announcing that that's now in you I can
see why they would be so upset about it
um cuz it's like we've had it this way
for a minute and like it's been okay and
then now we're switching it to something
very like drastic it's like going back
in time what if you are you might feel
like they're losing control like the
religion is falling apart people aren't
you know respecting what they should be
doing like it's getting too liberal
they're only getting more strict
something like really intense kind of
like as a catalyst that swords like more
extremist they're like oh this Instagram
hoenn in Indonesia is and then like like
they see all the [ __ ] girls in Bali
like wearing g-strings and [ __ ] and then
they're like we got to change this but
they did say though that the owners of
these coffee shops restaurants and cafes
that they it would be up to them to
enforce it no I mean I mean technically
it's not a crazy concept because it's
associated with like you know a religion
and a faith right yeah like I'm just
there's a bunch of crazy religions of
faith and even in like America you know
so Merkel but how is it punished like is
it by law like you get in trouble like
an uppercut to the stomach so no they're
saying that offenders won't be punished
they're just now there's like banned
like they're just not allowing maybe
they can kick them out or they can just
be like or they just refuse service
like if you're like a Muslim coffee shop
owner and you don't agree with this then
you can kick out and say like oh wait
we're not married yeah
legal discrimination yeah get out I feel
like it's hard for me so so here's my
thought on this to me it's like there's
really right or wrong it really depends
on the group I don't think there's a
ultimate right or wrong yes right like
people majority of it is cultural right
like Dobie Dobie societies that are just
like headhunters they'll be like for
them eating human flesh is okay and
that's a part of that
does it make it okay to murder I don't
think so but then in that world you know
I mean that's their thing and there's
just a lot of sick and twisted weird
things that go on but I'm like that's
their world yes that's definitely not
the worst of like you know religious
concepts that seem sad though like if
you're trying to plan a Valentine's Day
party you kind of don't want to hire
these guys to plan free you know they
don't they're not romantic or not
romantic at I don't see pink hearts I
see maybe a couple black hearts I'll see
a pink cards or purple hearts I don't
even see hearts I just see a lot of
people [ __ ] chaperoning it making
sure you don't damage bowling you this
whole video they're trying to keep it
together by like the mixture of
chauffeur it's easier to just say that
way those this is not Japanese is the
English language you need to respect it
but the fur is funnier like November
November
[Laughter]
you
[Music]